cuz I can't rap it's our privilege
Caucasian when it comes to race and
rhymes there is no correlation to give a
word
sorry I'll simplify wait when are your
balls gonna drop it's not gonna be at
dawn I'm not talking about tea bagging
Sean alright you done did it you just
get killed it you hip-hop is dead
I don't Oh what is going on YouTube
there are a few of things in this world
that'll make me make this face right
here this video here is about two teens
that decide to freestyle rap battle each
other in the dormitory of the halls
there are so many things wrong with this
video I don't even know where to start
uh blissed-out with a white boy
freestyle rule number one if you rollin
in the dough act like you ain't got it
though Oh Dave you must think he's rich
because he's white no the [ __ ] was
reading off a laptop I help me look
we're not coming to cut system you would
pick you I had no idea
Jason Mraz was pursuing a rap career she
and I had no idea of Malibu's Most
Wanted was making the TV series
freestyle rule number two never have
more than one white person in the crowd
it just don't look right if you notice
they had had the cast of The OC chillin
in the background with the celebrity
guest appearance from Rosie O'Donnell
right [ __ ] gonna win they're like have
a proline miss and jock that not
beheaded hair obviously you did not grow
up in an area with a lot of brothers
it's pronounced nappy not not be little
[ __ ] alright that's [ __ ] I began
[ __ ] since elementary being an Asterix
into penitentiary
later oh my but I don't even know to say
I'm pretty sure the moment you started
backing the whole black committee shed a
tear just like I know you think you can
rap Nevada was your choice but got some
bass in your [ __ ] soft that voice how
are you gonna talk about somebody else's
voice being high-pitched I'm not gonna
lie man and this is not a race thing
I did not expect your voice to be that
high-pitched and how you gonna freestyle
battle somebody with the leash then you
got this whole Mike Tyson thing going on
Plunkett's more intense one thing
everybody for the kraang Commission you
can't get [ __ ] to be paid I got a
better chance turning the KKK my brother
aside from your Hillary dumb ass voice I
find it hard to believe cuz if you
honestly believe that you have not seen
your reflection quite a few years
because you make what's it's like [ __ ]
like fish my own should i shown a gob of
that video and even he was like god damn
you dark and why the hell did you write
your free stuff better on a high school
transcript stop giggling every time you
got a goddamn punchline told me you got
a little dick
I do women you [ __ ] look boy is Sean
right and stop saying all right after
every first penny puberty all right I'll
teabag and Sean all right it goes out at
the age of 10 all right I got girls away
all right I don't even know why I'm
calling this a freestyle battle because
everything was written now every time I
come around the block you ain't go you
were I'm not a dream killer if you have
dreams to be a rapper go ahead do get
bang boss dream all playing but if you
go rap like that keep it to your goddamn
self
man look YouTube here's something that
you may or may not know about me okay I
used to want to be a rapper too I even
had a rap values sesame sprinkles but I
developed something that a lot of people
don't have it's called self awareness I
realize that this right here is too much
material to make fun of in a freestyle
I'm over here with this schoolboy
haircut looking like I barely speak
English hey daddy where's mommy
let me show you how my first freestyle
battle went down are you for serious you
want me to bail this little punk-ass
[ __ ] right here all right man I'm about
to rip this full up and you'll listen
look i'ma rip this punk-ass little okay
okay okay
listen yo okay okay okay oh oh oh oh oh
okay
okay okay okay okay you think you better
than me because you got an NBA salary
well imma get a college degree and you
still probably gonna make more money
than me Hollis okay that's alright
and they'd say I'm my dick